hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
là
je suis à
sinon on repasse au final si leur mais
moi aussi fait pas cher je leur pose
on attend et on se fait pas les uns ça
fait mal tu lui faire mal à des gens
dont on ne sait pas l'esprit de
coubertin
[Applaudissements]
attends c'est le tir en fait c'est
lebron james allen
[Applaudissements]
arrêt
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez moi j'étais volontaire et
actes indécents
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]